hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen actually in my kitchen
today we're going to be eating like the
goop Queen herself Gwyneth Paltrow minus
the detox of course a very quick
disclaimer though I'm using gwyneth's
alleged diet recall as a fun
entertaining example to build on to meet
my own unique needs this is not a
challenge where I force myself to eat in
a way that doesn't feel good to me just
reviews I honestly think that that
format is pretty problematic this is a
fun Twist on my traditional format to
give you some real world examples on how
to build out hunger crush and combo
balanced meals before we get too far
into it let me tell you my sponsor
cerebral so I've been very open about my
struggles with anxiety insomnia and
mental health and concerning that 50 of
the general population has a mental
health condition I know that I'm not
alone I acknowledge that I've been super
privileged to be able to access
therapists and doctors and other
supporters when I need them but I also
know how many of you message me to tell
me that there are so many Financial time
and stigma related barriers to getting
the help that you need so I was really
excited when I heard about cerebral
cerebral is a 100 online mental health
subscription that provides clients with
ongoing comprehensive access to therapy
and medication management for anxiety
depression insomnia and other conditions
for a flat monthly rate this is really
your One-Stop shop for all things mental
health care it's super convenient
because they operate on your schedule
where you can work visits in from the
comfort and privacy of your own home
whenever it's convenient for you they
also have a mobile app that allows you
to message your care team with questions
and access CBT exercises between visits
they have therapists that specialize in
grief trauma stress family issues
anxiety depression and more and it's way
more affordable than and typical therapy
they actually have three different plans
depending on your needs you simply fill
it a short online form and from there
you can select from the medication and
Care Management medication and therapy
or therapy plan so this sounds like it
may be helpful for you or someone you
care about check out the link in my
description and get access to the
questionnaire to get started today okay
so according to our girl guani uh she
generally just has coffee for breakfast
um and then just goes like straight to
the gym and has a big thing of water
with two packets of this like goop glow
powder for vitamin C and skin apparently
which she says I'm obsessed with that
stuff it's like my morning kind of
orange juice you guys know the drill on
coffee you drink it how you like it so
I'm gonna drink my coffee how I like it
and as for the Vitamin C powder yeah I'm
gonna pass I took a closer look at these
goop glow packets and they're apparently
formulated with antioxidants like
vitamin and C and vitamin E to help
stimulate collagen production in the
skin and protect against oxidative
damage two packs of the goop glow
provides only 20 calories along with 13
times the recommended daily dose of
vitamin C and three times your
recommended vitamin E as for their
benefit for skin one large study found
that higher intakes of vitamin C was
associated with a lower likelihood of
wrinkles and skin dryness while another
study found that when taken together
vitamin C and vitamin E can help to
reduce the risk of sun damage but if
you're getting a wide range of colorful
fruits and vegetables nuts and seeds in
your day as our girl Gwyneth obviously
does it's probably an unnecessary
purchase so yeah I personally didn't
feel like spending 60 bucks to try this
powder when I have a lot of food in the
fridge that will do the trick also I get
that Gwyneth prefers not to eat before
her workout but I prefer to have at
least a little fuel in the tank so I'm
going to have a couple of these little
oranges from my vitamin C and I've got
some roasted almonds for the Vitamin E
plus of course some protein and healthy
fat
here's a question Brody does the smell
of orange peel on your fingers uh excite
you or make you want to throw up I mean
I don't really know if I have a feeling
I need I need you to have this
experience with me because it's it's a
really offensive experience I hate the
smell of I like oranges I hate the smell
of orange peels my dog you should see
this poppy come here come here come here
now she likes most food but
what do you think of that
see
stinks but
I do like a little good orange
those are good ones all right now it's
time to get a little activity in for the
day we are going to be doing a classic
La Tracy Anderson workout which I'm
actually pretty excited about who
Gwyneth Praises for
I've actually never done a Tracy
Anderson workout but I actually
definitely looks like it's my style and
I found a 15 minute workout of hers on
the goop website which I was like very
excited about because who doesn't want
to do a quickie workout in 15 minutes
all right I'm gonna get changed and I'll
meet you in the gym
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
that was actually really fun I would
probably do that kind of workout again
but now yeah girl is hungry so
apparently for a post-workout gweny says
so I try to have a smoothie that has
some good fat and some protein and some
Fiber so sometimes I'll have like a
cacao and almond butter smoothie with
some spinach and some protein powder she
also says that she doesn't have the
smoothie that she'll have some kind of
like this like peanut butter protein bar
that you can't remember the name out of
I'm pretty hungry I'm not gonna lie like
a few oranges and some almonds is not
enough of a meal for me nor is a
smoothie so I'm gonna do both and see
how that goes and just know that lunch
is just like a couple hours away but
also I'm not gonna do the cacao news
because yeah that is gross to me I don't
want to yuck someone's yum but cacao
nibs are just like never gonna satisfy a
chocolate craving for me they're kind of
like chalky and grainy and they're super
bitter they're just like a big no in my
cacao nibs are basically small crushed
cocoa beans so they have a very bitter
dark chocolate flavor but they're rich
in fiber are naturally low in sugar and
have the highest flavonoid content by
weight of any other food so they're
often used as a healthy chocolate
alternative in Wellness circles an
unacceptable one if you ask me but you
do you but a Queenie likes them I mean
great I'm gonna make up for the Lost
antioxidants by adding in some really
nice dark cherries so this is my
favorite smoothie let's do it frozen
cherries
I buy ripe bananas by like the Dozen
literally and then I'll just freeze them
for doing things like this like
smoothies Gwyneth doesn't put bananas in
hers but I feel like it really needs
some extra carbs and sweetness these
resealable bags
kind of Chunk
chunk chunk
but enough slow down Hearts you guys
know me
to healthy fats in there plus lots of
protein we got the almond butter which
is apparently a favorite of gwyneth's as
well lots of fiber that oh no
protein
Mass
you name it
what else what else what else what else
what else all right she says there's
protein powder in hers we're going to
put protein powder in ours the key is
that I'm using chocolate protein powder
so that we get the kind of chocolate
flavor that she's after with the cacao
nibs which to me is not like chocolate
flavor all right a little bit of milk
that's not enough this is like a
non-dairy protein milk a little more
and you know what just to make it extra
chocolatey
because I'm feeling that this is my
husband's
specialty chocolate milk it's A2
chocolate milk when he picks himself up
to something from a grocery store which
is like never it's basically only
chocolate milk so I'm just going to use
a little bit of that you won't know all
right let's see if that's enough liquid
clearly not
[Applause]
she's thick that's kind of how I like
smoothies okay let's get organized
because I feeling like this is just a
mess
look at that
that looks so good
and I got some left over people ask me
in another video maybe on Tick Tock
about a smoothie like what do you do
with the leftovers you like you eat them
or drink them just like another time
way too thick to go through that straw
that's quite the journey you can see it
tried but my sucking my sucking capacity
just wasn't quite strong enough
I'm really determined now
I got a bit but that's gonna take that
will take it'll take me all day to drink
to drink it through there so that's what
we're doing
I can't even get out of the other end
this is this is me a spoonable smelly
ball
it's so creamy and good and because like
I said a smoothie is not enough for me
for a meal even if I were to drink like
seconds I also grabbed myself a peanut
butter bar to go with it so this will be
a little combo I might need two of these
not gonna lie I just felt like gwyneth's
version was already so low carb I added
in lots of carbs but I still definitely
need more so
um bro do you want to try
okay
okay so I'm gonna go get a little bit of
work done
um and then I'm gonna meet you back here
and lunch
all right folks I am super hungry and
ideally for something other than like an
erwan inspired expensive drink let's see
what our girl has for lunch so I'm
usually eating for lunch stuff that you
would see on the goop website like um a
salad with some protein or sometimes
they're testing something really fun for
detox like you know they're using jicama
for taco shells
um I didn't know that the words fun and
detox could be put in the same sentence
but yeah here we are I get that this
whole thing is kind of like just part of
gwyneth's brand just a friendly reminder
to everyone that you don't need to do
anything or take anything or eat
anything specific to detox your body
your body's got your back you've got
lungs and kidneys and a liver and skin
to do that for you every day all day
anyway I looked up this fun detox recipe
on the goop website and honestly it
looks pretty delicious like I love
jicama as like a raw veggie and some
salad or just like to eat like a carrot
stick with like a really good dip but do
we really need to say that it's going to
make a healthier Taco like [ __ ] that
this meal is like way too low carb and
low calorie for me especially in the
context of guanathe so yeah I'm gonna
make tacos but I'm gonna make it with
like a real taco shell like a real
tortilla because you're girl needs some
energy here folks also I'm going to kind
of like cut out most the steps because
who has time to make like four different
in-depth from scratch meal components on
a weekday for lunch not this girl let's
do it all right let's pan fry some
shrimp
wash my hands
a million times a day
some salt will keep it nice and simple
so that way my kids will eat part of it
God forbid I put pepper on it I see a
little respect and they freak out so I'm
gonna just
Hold Steady on that we'll just let these
babies cook up
smells so good
shrimpy shrimpy shrimp all right guys
let's make some tacos all right just
cutting up a little extra veggie veg
just for snacking on the side looks good
nice
hmm
all right how are we gonna do this okay
first things first
let's just stop talking about my
mouthful okay
looks like we're low on Mayo but you
guys know how I feel about this
I don't like scooping out Mayo
but I just need a tiny bit because I'm
going to make a little sauce okay sour
cream I can do just a little less
offensive of a gloopy sound you don't
like the sound of the Mayo jar this is
white guys that's why I don't like the
Mayo it's like
[Music]
that's what Mayo feels like to me and
it's triggering I don't like that I
don't like the sound of it when I put my
spoon in the jar anyways moving on we've
got a little bit of mayo and some sour
cream
I would have used yogurt but I only have
vanilla yogurt in the house so that
wasn't no and then this is like a little
bit of like a homemade it's not homemade
by me but like by a by the farmer's
market people
um a little Tajin and then I guess we'll
do a little lime zest
until 9 meters
and
a tiny bit of juice
much
just enough to loosen her up
that's what she said sorry that one's
for you a little more salt
all right let's do it maybe a little
more lime because I like it limey I like
it limey and I like it loose
oh I am just the gift that keeps on
giving am I not
oh
uh um okay let's put this together I've
gone for three tacos I feel like that's
gonna satisfy me I need to just cut a
little avocado
okay let's pray the avocado gods that it
is ripe and not rotten oh
[Music]
pretty good all right a little avocado
smashy smash
you know what I like to get more avocado
in every bite so we just have to do a
bit of a smash situation a couple
shrimps
that
Boop some I had some cabbage here that I
just had in the house for a little
crunch
I had some pineapple and I was like ah
yeah pineapple and shrimp are fire
together so we're doing that let's put
them onto our plate one two and three
and then we'll cram it Crema it up
well
that's just going to have to be the way
it looks we got protein in our shrimp we
got healthy fats in our avocado we've
got carbs and fiber in our whole grain
tortillas plus lots of fiber rich veg I
mean I'm excited to eat this a lot more
than I would be excited to eat like a
flimsy jicama wrap Bottoms Up
mmm
that's professional okay so I just
picked up my kids from school and I'm
here to meet you back for a snack okay
so according to Gwyneth around 3 to 4
P.M she heads to the goop snack cupboard
I would love one of those usually at
about
three or four I'll hit the snack covered
at the goop office maybe I'll have some
cashews or pretzels or something like
that but I usually need something salty
and crunchy in the afternoon and then
I'll usually have a cup of green tea
with that and then that will hold me
through till dinner love this journey
for her and in my case me minus the
green tea because I have like a hard 10
a.m caffeine cut off Abby I know you're
super sensitive and you want to go to
bed at like 8 PM but you'd probably be
okay with a small cup of wheat tea green
tea is generally a lot lower in caffeine
than coffee about 30 to 50 milligrams
depending on how strong the brew and a
lot of sensitive folks prefer the
effects of green tea over coffee because
the amino acid l-theanine and green tea
helps to provide the alertness that we
want without the crash okay I don't have
a goop snack cover but I do have a
pantry with a lot of snacks so I'm
loving in the pretzel idea I'm loving
the cashews here we go but I feel like I
need like a little extra protein in the
snack so let's just see where we are
beef jerky more nuts
oh
crispy chickpeas so good love the extra
crunch
so good
run away
this is the beigest snack plate I've
ever made but
still very nutritious and hella
delicious
okay so it's time for me to work on
dinner because Gwyneth also enjoys a
geriatric dinner hour hashtag motherhood
so let's take a look what she has and
then for dinner you know my kids love
Asian food so we'll have some kind of
Asian fish noodles on the side oh I am
definitely feeling this I found a recipe
for like a steamed halibut on the goop
website I couldn't find halibut that was
fresh and looked good but I got some
salmon so I'm gonna try that out plus
I'm going to do it with like like a
noodle vegetable stir fry let's get to
it all right so let's see what we got to
do here okay
we've got
some parchment paper I'm going to throw
down some bok choy leaves which we love
little salty salts
all right we've got some salmon here
some ginger on top like that we need a
little bit of sesame oil
got a little bit of mirin
just a stitch
and some soy sauce
all right a little extra salt and pepper
now we wrap
well this is tough
never really good at this
I'm doing good I do a pretty job
good enough
let's put it down the oven
a little oil
I'll throw a little bit of this
green onion
a little bit of garlic a little bit of
ginger
a little bit
I am not measuring anything because I
don't know how to all right let's stir
fry some veg
foreign
gonna make up a sauce right here folks
let's see we'll stir up made some
sriracha
looking like a good Arsenal
oh
whatever
using coconut aminos
a little bit
of sesame oil
a little bit of oh [ __ ] rice vinegar
I'm gonna add in my noodles
come on break up
break up folks oh no
this is somebody's a problem with these
noodles oh
chaos
why they gotta be so damn sticky
following what the instructions said on
the package they didn't say they were
going to stick together so
aggressively well we're gonna have
chunks of noodles chunks are better than
no noodles
oh that's gonna be
spiciest
there we go
all right
that looks good all right looks like our
salmon is cooked and ready
mmm smells like really deliciously
gingery what's going on
I feel like this needs a garnish I had a
little sesame seed action
looks so good
all right let's talk about what I did
for this meal we got lots of healthy
fats and protein in our salmon we got
some carbs on our noodles we've got tons
of fiber rich veg it looks amazing and I
am very excited to dig in
so um okay so I get the sense that
Gwyneth is not exactly like a big fan of
sweets or like even carbs in general so
according to her Harvest Bazaar
interview she prefers a liquid dessert
and it is Friday when we are filming
this like Brody I'm not mad about it I
usually have a Gibson that's kind of my
new thing which is like a vodka martini
but with the cocktail onions it's very
my father or I'll have whiskey on the
Rocks like a Japanese whiskey on the
rocks usually I mean not exactly my
style like I'm more of like a spicy Mark
or like a Pinot Grigio kind of girl but
you know when in Rome all right first
things first
we need a shaker
I don't think there's any vodka here but
I'll take this
so according to my very scientific
research
we just need
vodka
and vermouth we got that
should we go with the good stuff yes yes
we should all right let's do it to make
Martini let's take a look two and a half
ounces of vodka half an ounce of dry
vermouth all right let's do this I don't
have a martini glass
because I'm not that fancy
okay half an ounce oh
[Music]
TGIF baby
oh God
oh I need ice yeah just an ounce of
vodka yeah yeah yeah
and I believe we need a lemon
uh yeah we don't need lemon in this
recipe we don't we don't
why is it cloudy
is that normal okay
and then apparently there's like a
pickled onion situation going on
I prefer maraschino cherries but
we're doing a gweny's way
it's been a hard week but folks
yeah I'm gonna like pass on that and
just like
have an after dinner snack instead
well folks what can we say about our
goopy goop girlfriend gwenny's day of
eating well had I not made some like
liberal mods I probably would have been
hungry as
also probably just like really
emotionally unsatisfied and like riddled
with Cravings I just felt like there was
just not enough calories or carbs in her
day of eating and the onion martini
just didn't hit the workout was kind of
fun though I mean weird but fun I would
maybe try it again but anyways that's
all that I have for you guys today if
you like this format please let me know
in the comments below let me know whose
diet you'd like to see me try and Abby
thigh don't forget to subscribe to this
Channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]